cette boutique de produits en vrac ferme
ses portes demain demain on a décidé de
fermer effectivement
pour envoyer un message clair qu' on est
rendu ailleurs comme société que la
planète a besoin plus d'un black-out que
d'un black friday
voici à quoi ressemblaient les vendredis
fou avant la pandémie une véritable
course aux aubaines mais un mouvement de
contre culture s'oppose à cette culture
dominante de consommation effrénée ce
qu'on veut conscience et c'est l'impact
de la consommation abusive ou de la
consommation irréfléchie le black friday
on est bombardé le de
publicité tout le monde veut nous faire
consommer à tout prix l'observatoire de
la consommation responsable de l'uqam
analyse le phénomène et constate que
depuis la pandémie 57% des consommateurs
québécois ont changé leurs habitudes de
consommation pour les rendre plus
responsables le vendredi fut classique
est en train de s'essouffler le
consommateur oui cherche des rabais mais
il cherche aussi un sens à sa
consommation l'objectif ce n'est pas de
ne pas consommer mais c'est de consommer
différemment de mieux consommer il ya
aussi des accessoires théo déchets qui
nous permet de réduire après notre
consommation une épicerie écologique
zéro déchet qui a décidé de redonner à
la communauté demain en fait on va
remettre 10% de tous nos revenus
l'affect pas juste les profits bras tous
les revenus pour des organismes locaux
il s'agit d'une prise de conscience qui
fait des adeptes le fait d'avoir des
rabais qui n'a majoritairement sons sont
très peu attrayant où les prix ont été
gonflées juste pour la journée en fait
le puits font que ça vaut vraiment la
peine je cours aussi je trouve que nous
consommons beaucoup
une réflexion qui tombe à point à la
veille de la période de noël issigeac
bissonnet radio-canada à prévost dans
les laurentides